trois jours avant la crise d'oka que sa
mère que s'émouvoir pour un autre projet
que je travaille avec eux sur la cuisine
régionale au québec on essaie
d'implanter les produits du québec à
travers
et puis ça mais rochus m'avait dit de
venir cacher tant parce qu'il vient pour
personne sache qui était la cause de
gruissan autour jours avant alors moi
j'avais dit et kopf attention à toi là
un vrai côté sommes là où ils sont
mitraillette au maximum une trentaine de
warriors qui viennent d'un peu partout
du vietnam hockey qui ont fait la guerre
du vietnam j'avais des amis rétine qui
travaillait pour moi puis une d'entre
elle son fils est un des oies rieuses
elles sont armés de mitraillettes fait
jaser à semur qu'est-ce que ça ne
répondit michel jamais compris jamais
qu'on va monter en moi quand ils voient
que leurs 11 au matin
quand j'entends des dix hélicoptères
qu'est ce qui se passe à mercus
magnétique jamais alors que dans
quelques secondes on entend dire
beaucoup de mitraillettes beaucoup de
coups de feu alors la nature et mathilde
ils m'ont dit que caporal lemay était
d'essayer
et puis moi je me suis dit quand j'ai vu
la mort d'un homme inutile
mozy club de golf le plus bluesy la
messe pour moi c'était ça